-Not only Margot Robbie,
but in "Mary Queen of Scots"
you also have --
I guess there's four actresses
who were your ladies in waiting.
-Yeah. Four Marys.
-Yeah. The four other Marys.
Did you get to be,
unlike Margot obviously,
pretty much all -- so many of
your scenes were with them.
-Yeah.
-Did you get to be
close with them?
-Yeah, we're so close.
We're really, really
good friends.
We basically -- The more time
we spent with each other,
the more we realized, like,
we're basically the renaissance
Spice Girls.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause there's five of us and I
was Ginger Spice, obviously.
She's the best one.
And we had a Sporty Spice and
a Baby Spice and all of that.
And we used to like, full out --
full on, perform "Wannabe"
on set in our corsets and with
our massive head pieces.
♪♪ If you wanna be my lover ♪♪
-This is your range as an actor.
-Yeah.
-Which is one part of you as
an actor as like to Margot,
"I don't want to see you
until we shoot the scene."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then the other part
of you is like,
"Hey, let's be Spice Girls."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, duality. That's Saoirse.
-Yes.
You have to speak French
in the film.
-Yeah.
-You learned it.
I'm very impressed because I
would have thought,
based on seeing it,
that you knew French.
-Yeah. I heard your mother was
a -- was a French teacher.
-Yeah, she was a middle school
French teacher.
-So how's your --
-It's not good.
-And she was my teacher.
So, you know,
it reflects badly on her.
-Oh, well, that's why then.
-Yeah.
-That's why you aren't good.
I do think it's
why I'm not good
because she was pretty --
she was pretty forgiving
with the old grades.
-Right. Okay. Okay.
Did she draw little smiley faces
next to your grades?
Or like -- or like, "pick you up
at 3:00 p.m., darling"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like little hearts.
-It was bad 'cause
the other kids would see it.
You know? It would come back.
And they'd see that
all my answers were wrong.
But there were
just smiley faces.
-Terrible. Terrible.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was -- it was a bad scene.
I think --
-So I could probably out-French
you, then.
-Yeah. How do --
-Bonjour.
-Oh, very good.
[ Laughter ]
[ Conversing in French ]
-But you -- you got to go --
-That's Italian.
[ Laughter ]
-French is this.
-French is that.
[ Laughter ]
French is --
-French is --
-It's a reverse Italian.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- This is very exciting.
Greta Gerwig who, obviously,
directed "Lady Bird."
You just finished working with
her again on "Little Women."
That is a thrill, so exciting
that you guys
teamed up for that.
Was that a book you were
familiar with, "Little Women"?
-Yes. I'm very familiar with it.
I read it all the time
when I was a kid.
And there's been, you know,
so many versions of it.
So I grew up watching
all of them --
the Winona version,
the Liz Taylor version.
And yeah. We wrapped yesterday.
-Oh, man.
-So it's kind of mental.
But we had an amazing time.
And she's -- she's just
so smart, Greta Gerwig.
-She's so smart.
-She's really smart.
-And one of the things she
talked about the last time
she was here is
no cellphones on set.
-No.
-Was that the case again?
-Yeah. I mean, I'm the same.
I hate having phones on set.
-Yeah.
-It's so --
It's just really distracting.
And also, you know,
we're in the 1800s.
And they didn't have
iPhones then.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
They had flip phones.
-They had flip phones.
They had Motorolas or something.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was like --
like the big brick phones
that you had to plug in
to your Lamborghini.
-Yeah.
-They had those.
-The March family
shared one of those.
-Yeah. It was bad.
-They were very poor.
-That was the thing. Yeah.
Families back then would have
one cellphone
for the whole family.
-Yeah. It was tough.
It was tough.
-And very limited minutes.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like 100 minutes a week
or like 50 texts or something.
-You're going to Ireland
for Christmas?
-Going to Ireland for Christmas.
Yeah.
-Exciting.
Is your shopping done?
-Shopping's all done.
I do everything online now
because shops
just stress me out anyway.
-Of course.
-And I'm -- I don't know
what you're like.
But I'm a sitter more so
than a stander.
So I don't like standing for
prolonged periods of time.
-Gotcha.
-And in shops, there's
a lot of like...that for a bit.
And I'm just not into it.
So instead I just sit on
my couch and do that.
-Yeah, that's way better.
You might have noticed.
For a -- I sit for a living.
-You sit for a living.
You've gotten very good at it.
-I like sitting
so much I said --
I said I need
a desk job every day.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you -- Do you spin?
-What do you mean?
-Do you ever -- do you ever kind
of think like, "You know what?
I could do more with this."
-Is -- Oh, you mean like --
-Do you ever spin around
or go back?
-When the show is over
and everybody leaves,
I give it one big spin.
-Just one big spin?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And just see how long I can go,
and then whenever it stops,
I go home, yeah.
-All the lights are out.
-Have a little cry.
-Yeah, 35, that's my record.
-35, that's pretty good.
That's really good.
-Thanks for being here.